Yeah.
In this video we'll look at what is the
capacity of a multilayer neural network.
Now we are already seeing that and
artificial single artificial neuron was
limited at its capacity.
There are certain classification problems
that it cannot actually model if it's,
if they're not linearly separable.
However,
we've looked at an approach where we
would first learn a representation or
transformation of our original
space, uh, in such a way that,
uh, we could get a new
representation where the data
was then linearly separable.
And then we've used that as
a justification for having a,
what we call the single hidden
layer neural network, uh,
where we would first compute a
representation that hidden representation.
So I transformation of our input space
and hopefully in such a way that then the
output of our neural network could
then perform its jobs, its job more,
more, much more easily. So in the
context of classification, uh, so that,
uh, it could actually perform
the classification, uh,
in the, uh, original space,
perfectly distinguishing between the,
uh,
inputs in the class zero
on class one. Now, uh,
can we actually do a show anything
formal about that? So, in other words,
if we assume that we have a function of f,
f of x that takes this particular
form that computes a hidden,
they are pre activation
applies an activation function,
computes and output linear combination.
So literary combining the new
representation, linear representation, uh,
sorry,
hidden representation of uh,
the input and then applying
some activation function
at the output to have a
function that performs all
of these transformations.
What kind of functions can we actually
model with this particular form and other
functions that we cannot model?
So let's look at this a little bit and
try to get some intuition about around
this problem.
Cool.
No,
here's the first example where we have
a single layer neural network with two
hidden units,
which a compute these two functions here.
Okay.
Now, uh, you should be able
to convince yourself that, uh,
add the output layer.
If you have an output learner neuron,
then we can actually combine these two
hidden units to get a new function,
which respect to our original input.
That would actually look
something like this.
We'd get a ridge that goes up
here and then that goes down here.
And essentially the way we can get this
is by taking this neuron and subtracting
from it. Disney Rod.
So by getting a linear,
a combination of [inaudible]
with this neurons specifically,
essentially this neuron minus that neuron,
we can actually get a ridge that is a
localized in a particular range of a
combinations of x and x one
and x two values. So indeed,
if we're here,
then this neuron as a small value,
but this neuron too.
So we get a small value at the output.
Now if we're in this range,
sorry, excuse another color,
if we are in this range,
then this neuron that has a large value,
but there's some,
this neuron also still has a low value.
So because of that we get a
large value minus a low value.
So we get at the output
a fairly large value.
And then if we reach this part here,
then this is still large,
but this is now the second
neuron has not become larger.
So the value at the output we'll now
drop because we're not subtracting value
that has become larger at the
second, uh, hidden neuron.
So we see, so this is, you know,
intuitively how we can get
from these two simple neurons.
A more complicated output,
which is localized in a particular
range of x one and x two values.
And our weekend go,
uh,
into a context that's a bit
more complicated where we
could get for neurons that
would compute these four functions.
And by combining them in
a fairly similar fashion,
we can actually get a d output, a
localized bump. So four values, uh,
of these, uh, inputs x one and x two.
Within this part here,
we could get an output,
which actually is large and
a low everywhere else here.
Okay. And then we could actually, uh,
continue making a more complex output
by having four other neurons that would
allow us to compute, say,
another bump maybe here,
or maybe we could get a bump that's here
with these, uh, with four other neurons.
So we can see that by combining
in two dimensions, these, uh,
for neurons together and having sets of
four neurons for different parts of the
input space, we could actually add a
bunch of different bumps in different, uh,
parts of the space and
sort of carve out a, uh,
more and more complicated function.
So if we think of this,
uh,
if we go in the sending
of a classification, this
means that we could have,
uh, chunks of regions that
are actually separated and,
but that correspond to the same class.
So say that our two corresponds to
class one and our one class zero.
Then by having uh,
uh,
several bumps here and bumps here and
no bumps in the [inaudible] region here
and here,
we can actually get there
fairly complicated decision
and a fairly complicated
decision,
uh,
classification decision with a neural
network that could have enough,
um, hidden units to place
bumps at the right places.
Uh, uh, to model our
complicated decision function.
Not can we actually be formal about
this? Uh, well it turns out we can.
So we can show that a neural network with
a single hidden layer is actually what
is known as a universal
approximator. Uh, so, uh,
more specifically,
we can say that a single hidden layer
neural network with a linear output can
approximate any continuous function
arbitrarily well as long as it has enough
hidden units.
So this was shown by Hornik in 1991.
So there are more details and
technical details behind this theorem.
So I encourage you to
consult the original paper,
but this is essentially saying that if
you have a function which is continuous,
so that does not vary too much,
um,
then we can actually model it as long
as we give our neural network enough
hidden units. So there are
configurations of these, uh,
hidden units and the output unit,
there are values of their weights and
biases such that we can model any function
arbitrarily. Well, uh,
this was all actually applies whether
you're using sigmoid hidden units or tench
hidden units. And there
are also many other, uh,
hidden layer activation functions
that, uh, makes this result true that,
that complies with this result.
And so what this is saying is that
by using a neural networks, we,
uh,
are actually allowing ourselves to model
many types of arbitrarily complicated,
fairly arbitrarily complicated function.
So this is a pretty good result.
Now notice that it actually doesn't
mean that there is a learning algorithm.
So an algorithm that would find a
behavior, the parameters of these, uh,
of all the units in the neural network
that would actually, uh, allow us to,
uh, um, model any function.
So in other words,
uh, there might exists values
of the connections, uh,
weights and the biases for
a neural network with enough
hidden units that would
allow us to model any functional HR well,
but it doesn't mean that we actually have
the learning algorithm that will find
the values of these connections
and biases for any given function.
And, uh, this is, uh, an in fact,
there aren't really any known algorithm
that can do this for any types of
function. And, uh, we'll see that, uh,
actually this is a whole field of research
trying to develop more and more, uh,
improve learning algorithms
that can learn, uh,
more and more types of functions and
more specifically that can solve more and
more, uh, types of, uh,
problems usually related
to artificial intelligence.